this is not the outcome we wanted or we
worked so hard for and I'm sorry that we
did not win this election for the values
we share and the vision we hold for our
country Hillary Clinton's concession
speech on the morning of November 9th
the day after she was dealt a stunning
defeat in the presidential election now
ten months later Clinton is out with a
new memoir about the 2016 election what
happened published by Simon & Schuster a
division of CBS's Clinton's version of
events that led to her loss to Donald
Trump now in her first broadcast
interview about the book she sat down
with Jane Pauley of CBS Sunday morning
to discuss the moment during one of the
debates when Donald Trump got closer to
Clinton than she liked it was so just
calm Bob you lating and so while I'm
answering questions my mind is going
okay do I keep my composure do I act
like a president am I the person that
people can trust in the end to make hard
decisions or do I wheel around and say
get out of my space back up you creep
well you know I didn't do the latter but
I I thought you know people say well I
don't know her well and I think my
composure which I have developed over
years being in the public eye has well
equipped me for being a leader because
you should keep your cool and you should
be steady and predictable but I think in
this time we're in particularly in this
campaign you know maybe I missed a few
chances and you can see all of Jane
Pauley's interview with Hillary Clinton
tomorrow on CBS Sunday morning beginning
at 9:00 Eastern Time she thinks she
missed a few chances yeah I mean there's
so many questions I think people have
it'll be interesting to see if the
things people are wondering about are
the things that are addressed in the
book whether it be how she handled some
of the debates or whether it be how she
handled the election in a total when you
lose a campaign you go over it back over
it